[Laughter]
hello welcome back to big mood with the
Moo's are very big and the talk is big
too in the boobies are big and
everything's big big Oh big eyeballs
yeah so I said what do you think I said
I thought you said big eyeballs and I
was like that doesn't look good I don't
think we have big eyeballs I don't know
we have big balls metaphorically yes yes
mind angles my ankles a trip on him all
the time tied in a knot tied in a boat
no practice today we thought we'd be
talking about some romantic gestures
because we talk a lot about sex but what
about the romance guys like what do they
do to like earn it I know what about
that we face I know well for me usually
they get it first and then I expect the
willing to come after and then I'm like
hey what the [ __ ] and then they're like
oh I already got it so let's fix that
ladies let's not give in don't put a
down payment down yeah don't give away
the milk on the house that you haven't
toured yet the egg doesn't swim to the
sperm ladies no actually recently redid
a JK news article on how the egg selects
the sperm yeah and the like final moment
like the front you have five foot two
genes I'm not gonna do that does it make
a lot of sense though because then like
there's still a lot of issues with
children so it's like it's not very good
at selecting it was the best one my egg
was stupid apparently it likes cheating
spur better to know if it's not your
spouse I don't know oh yeah
oh god yeah that's what it said in the
article it was just one article though
so I didn't read a bunch of science
exercises never really like completely
refute especially when it's like a new
study came out yeah well maybe that may
be the cheater sperm or the the non
partner sperm has more dominant traits
because you know I'm taking this woman
yeah what are we talking about cheating
we're talking about romance okay sorry
right before we took the before we
started this episode we all take a shot
in the skull except wait Niki you didn't
take one I didn't but I feel like I do
sandwich I feel like drunk really sleepy
just like Niki like after our lunch was
like it's so strong that the fumes
coming out of my mouth will probably get
Niki drunk that's true that's probably
what it is actually
Niki taught it Niki taught me how to
drink yeah oh yeah we just got us how to
drink if you are drinking tequila get
your tequila bottles ready okay pour a
shot this is how you properly taste
tequila and it's how you can taste a
good quality to heal I don't do this
with tequila okay just do this with all
shots not vodka don't do a vodka
why because vodka is meant to not be
tasted it's meant to take on like the
mixture mixed flavor so but you know
high-quality tequila possibly gin
definitely whiskey okay
oh so whiskey and tequila mostly you use
the serum - okay yeah but I learned it
with tequila so I can't really vote for
the other ones but what you do so you
don't taste that alcohol taste you don't
have to use a lime you put it in your
mouth mm-hmm
put it in your mouth and then your
mother you breathe you breathe in while
it's in your mouth okay so do it take it
in our mouth without even sitting in
your mouth you read the ad breath inhale
swallow and then you breathe out through
your mouth and you suck dicks - yes and
make sure you breathe out through your
mouth not out through your nose
and it won't taste the flavor yes you
take everything not to burn see here's
the thing I hate liquor and I can never
drink it without looking like I'm gonna
bond - I always have this face one my no
my nostril is kind of going
so I'm just like yeah what the Mickey
taught us this and TIFF and I drink it
straight face yeah I was so proud of you
guys and me the person that drinks
tequila straight all the time because it
was my skull which is very ashtray
tastes like a boot it's definitely a
prefer some peas on my hair on your
chest you know I couldn't even focus on
the intense flavor of it all because I
was just so shocked that I didn't have
that nostril face and I'm like oh my god
this war yeah like a cheat sheet for
drinking like an adult God we're like
newly 21 against all the alcohol again
yeah speaking of when you were 21 how
was the romantic gestures I really got
to you what was it the thing that like a
guy had to do when you're like yes okay
so there was one guy this is when I was
young I was really broke and he knew
that I loved playing video games so he
for Christmas he got an Xbox set up at
his house and then a giant projector so
I can sit there and play all day one
another one was hello cancer he made so
I my love language is gifts receiving
gifts and giving gifts like that's how I
love to love and yeah I like material
things but the ones that sit really near
and dear to my heart are like that the
ones that they make and they put their
love into you right I don't help me a
gift what you mailed me again I did mail
or do is the same kind of thing like
it's less about the get like the
materialistic aspect of it but more
about like it was just taken it was an
inside joke type experience thinking of
you kind of yeah that's how I show love
like every time I go to sleep I think of
Gina because I hug the pillow that she
gave I got to find something to just
like eventually throughout the years
I'll find something find a grumpy bear
drop that person
so let's rebrand she's like I hate
mezcal I'm not that deserves to be hated
bright some very upset that you brought
that into my life so cute cuz Bryce like
sliced up all the organs like powder it
was that was really romantic I have to
say I feel very loved on it it reminded
me of my dad honestly because he came
out with the little tray yeah stuff you
put on top of it called chopped Aline's
chipolina jumpers wait excuse me good
little grasshoppers on them is so
romantic right
yeah oh my god yeah thank you for not
telling me prior yeah there's no is it
every level just give you bugs to eat
because I was like oh that's how you say
grasshopper it was like a good name you
know like pico de gallo yeah actually
eating [ __ ] rooster guy is rooster Oh
huevos rooster bikini balls regs but I
had a problem with when I was young I oh
wait you weren't finished with your
story were you anyhow just very quickly
my one of my favorite gifts ever he made
a picture frame with like he cut out our
photos and put it in there and like our
favorite comic books and stuff and was
the sweetest thing I was like I'm so mad
at you for having a boy or a friend a
guy friend or whatever he is that would
do that no one's ever done anything that
for me here that guy awful one maybe
[ __ ] yeah I feel like it's so simple
to like it doesn't have to be guys think
that they have to drop loads of money on
it's just like being thoughtful but I'll
tell you why no one's ever done anything
like that for me and we're gonna get
real deep right now it's because I
choose emotionally unavailable men
because I feel like I don't deserve to
be loved
and that's it thank you I love you
deserve to be loved I know I shy
honestly I do believe I deserve to be
loved and I think I will set it a
subconscious thing cuz I relate to that
because I'm like if you're all emotion
like yeah then when I want it I don't
get it I'm like what the [ __ ] how dare
you not give me something that I never
asked for it I actually reject you
rejecting their emotional advances or
something and then I'm like but you
don't do anything
excuse me wait am i right we all have
some sort of baggage and I will not try
to hide mine yo I got a [ __ ] baggage
claim full I hope you're ready to wait
for that they're like really like punk
and it's like covered in duct tape
[Laughter]
what's what's what's a problem was
similar to Jes was I romanticized you
probably because of movies or TV shows
or whatever but I just thought all
growing up through junior high until I
got a boyfriend that like oh my god when
I get a boyfriend he's gonna buy me so
much that Valentine's Day and it's gonna
be so cute he's gonna buy me rings and
like jewelry and like I would see
different girls that had boyfriends and
they would buy them like little even
like those carnival bear things I'd be
like oh my god that's ugh yeah they're
gonna pay for fireworks to go off every
time we kiss yeah and I'm super romantic
like in sentimental so if it's like our
one-month anniversary they better have
something for a month or well not now
okay
school I totally was but then but then
yeah the first guy that I kind of like
held hands with I wouldn't even call him
my boyfriend this was like we dated for
like two months didn't even kiss or
anything we just kind of held hands but
he was just like really quiet the whole
time and I was like he's not even being
a boyfriend and then my second my actual
first boyfriend he would give like gifts
but I don't know I guess like it was I
had already lost all my expectations and
it was when I lost the expectations that
I feel like it came cuz I was like just
so obsessed with finding a guy that was
like this and like I was oh the way I
got my first boyfriend to was I had a
crush on his friend like I was just
obsessed with trying to get his friend
to like me and like would like
romanticize what would happen if like we
ended up dating and what he would get me
and like or whatever like what kind of
romantic things we would do go on the
ferris wheel all together all kinds of
[ __ ] and then during that time I
befriended him because like he's like
the friendzone guy and we would just
have we just laughed the whole time and
like he'd make me laugh and he like
would learn my favorite things he would
order like my favorite foods he would
like if we went to Carl's jr. I like the
spicy chicken sandwiches and he would
like bring me back one if he went alone
just the little things like that's Yuri
oh man I love when they remember just
like a random thing you mentioned one
yeah so then they remember dates of
things to worry like oh I told him three
weeks ago that this thing was gonna
happen today and then they remember that
you're like how did you remember yeah
they even remember what you wore the
first day which is like really sweet I
would never I can't even I can't
remember at all he must have been so
[ __ ] hot that they were you know like
they took a shot of that
I remember whatever stay really wait on
what I wore when I will first met
because I have a photo oh right yeah
yeah yeah I don't even remember when I
first met you uh it was JK Newsday I
don't remember I meant remember no it's
just thinking friend well I do remember
you having brown hair I did for sure I
do actually remember when I met I was up
the JK off yeah and it was I feel like
you were wearing you ever pewter shirt
like what like a gray pewter I wore a
lot of gray
yeah it was gray and maybe long-sleeve I
think I remember TIFF the only the first
time I remember TIFF and I will always
remember this every time I see here the
word that pops into my head is tuna cake
tuna cake because this is when I make
that no I haven't made it in a long time
the first time I met sounds disgust it
does sound really absolutely trashes my
boyfriend it's cool thank you sorry I
used to do this whenever I feel sweet
cake okay every cake the first time I
met TIFF was when you in case moved into
a house in apartment in Monterey Park oh
you came to that barbecue and I came to
the barbecue was the first time I met
her as I go she's new like and this was
like I was already in JK for it a little
bit yeah and then she's new and then she
brings up this tray she's like I made
tuna cake I was like the [ __ ] is this
like oh but it was not bad yeah
literally like a casserole plate yeah
with breath it's kind of like okay it's
it's like a picture like a lasagna where
it's a lot of layers but the layers it's
sandwich bread you cut off the the crust
and then it's like this sauce like I
pour on top of it the sauce has like
mayo mustard chipotle sauce how about
baño sauce and a whole bunch other stuff
Angelina
yeah like tuna it's a casserole [ __ ]
yeah well it was like it was like a tuna
fish sandwich put into a casserole yeah
but it's all square and then so that's
first in my head I was like what the
[ __ ] is you we remake it I tried it you
want to try it I'll make it again that's
all white people [ __ ] tuna cake I'm sure
it's good that's all the ingredients I
probably would eat no yeah but you know
what for me though like going back to
the romantic gesture stuff or I guess
like since we're talking about
like when we first met like for me like
the memory I have with Jess's I mean
sorry with Gina is that like we were at
a JK shoot and that was the first time I
remember meeting you and then I remember
complimenting you on your ring you had a
ring on and I was like glad such a cute
ring this [ __ ] took it off and gave it
to me like we had just met and I was
like what's the most romantic shaver
yeah I was like this is like oh my god
I'm like I like your necklace but like I
mean okay so approaching Gina she's like
[ __ ] gorgeous right so you see her
and then also coming from like the
friends that I had like the neighborhood
I grew up in like pretty girls are not
nice like they're just not mine so as
soon as you did that I was like she has
my heart oh my god like that II don't
remember this is just something that you
do naturally was like a big deal for you
still have that ring so guys a way you
can translate for men out there the way
that you can translate this is like you
should show up to a first date wearing a
Rolex watch I really love that watch you
take it off and give it to her I mean
you will absolutely bag that chick
what's a romantic thing that Steve has
done for you oh my gosh he's always with
romantic scene Jamba Juice craving Jamba
Juice he disappears comes back with the
[ __ ] Java jizz like who does that
servant to the max but in the best part
like I own I did not trade him to be a
servant at all he just loves it like I I
am very he actually hates that I'm like
so self functioning like yeah he
absolutely loves to take care of me I
really isn't that for sure because he
has such a great balance of being like a
dominant like he's still very like he's
very sure of himself he doesn't [ __ ]
let people walk all over him
very stubborn okay very
yeah I mean I've watched you guys like
have little arguments or whatever and
you guys are both very [ __ ] stubborn
but then also like the the fact that he
serves you in such a giving way it's
just insane that that can all be in one
person yeah yeah absolutely and I didn't
think that that could have like I lost
hope of that happening he's very rare
but yeah that's true and I was like I
saw mine I was single I saw him treat
his girlfriend like that and I was like
there are guys that treat their
girlfriend like that and I was like I
want to date someone exactly like Steve
green that's why I wrote it in my
journal I've told this story before but
but yeah I just like I kind of just when
you have a template of what you what you
really really want and and it has to
serve your love language to like
obviously I don't know if everybody
would like that type of love maybe some
people yeah or some people might be like
you only gave me a dhama deuce
because like we were broke as [ __ ] when
we first started dating it wasn't like
crazy but I will say when we first
started dating the first well the first
date was romantic because I had a
romantic gesture because we were we went
to we went on a date and we had just
been on set like a week before we used
to do sketches together on a channel
called totally sketch that's how we met
and we I was putting craft service into
my purse and he was like any money I had
went towards feeding my cats so I would
buy a six-pack of beer and just like
drink one a day and like that was my
nutrients and my drink Wow I was like my
dinner so I was piling off service that
no one was had no idea I struggled that
hard oh yeah it was taking food I was on
unemployment yeah it was really bad and
I couldn't it wasn't because I wanted to
be on unemployment I was trying to get
another restaurant job but yeah so he he
I didn't even know he remembered this
but I was on set I was putting in craft
service and he was like what are you
doing I was like oh like I don't have
enough money for groceries so I just do
this because I won't feed my cats with
my any money
and on our first day after the whole
date he you know paid for the day took
me out to sushi it was so fun
went to a movie he brought me home and
as we were kissing which I made I made
the first but he was probably like okay
it's a good sign and then like as we
were kissing he's like oh his fell out
of your purse and he put something in my
purse and then I go upstairs and I'm
like what the hell like that definitely
didn't fall my purse and I go upstairs
and I opened it and it was a gift
certificate to Ralph's $50.00 it didn't
say how much on there I had to find out
but it had a note that was like here you
bring my to my craft service girl get
yourself some real gross longer I would
have taken him to bed in my broke-ass
comforter unfortunately I did not have
the mattress I currently own right now
which is a purple mattress so I have
owned this mattress since like 2016
actually bought it off of an ad too so
you guys should definitely check out
purple it has some really cool
technology so the secret to purple is
the purple grid it's a pet patented
comfort technology that instantly adapts
to your body's natural shape and sleep
style purple is for every body no matter
how you sleep
purple is designed with over 2,800 open
air channels and naturally temperature
neutral gel you'll never sleep too hot
or too cold and I can attest to this
because like I said I've had this
mattress for a very long time and I love
it so mat the purple mattress is soft
where you want it it's firm where you
need it and comfortable comfortably cool
all over it's truly a mattress that does
it all
now I've seen a picture and they look
cool yes side profile cut thing that
thing's cool I know it's so cool and
then it's also awesome too because when
they deliver it to your home they give
you a little sample of the purple grid
and it's like really squishy and really
fun it's kind of like it almost looks
like a honeycomb kind of thing remember
he showed me that and we were just
sitting there like make it
noise with its really soft but yet it's
really firm so that's why I really like
this mattress so the purple is so
confident in what they do that every
purple mattress comes with free shipping
and returns and a risk-free 100 night
trial so you can little log pies for a
whole 100 nights and you can make up
your own mind if you love it or not so
experience the new evolution of sleep go
to purple comm slash big mood and use
promo code big mood for a limited time
you'll get 150 dollars off any purple
mattress order of 1,500 or more that's
purple calm / big mood promo code big
mood for 150 dollars off any mattress
order of 1,500 or more
alright and our next sponsor is one of
my absolute absolute favorites is
function of beauty our favorite shampoo
yes because it's smell dinner it does
smell amazing and you get to choose what
smell you want I'm like you don't you a
beauty tip wow
thank you function of beauty is a
haircare formulated specifically for you
no matter your hair type they create
shampoo conditioner and other treatments
to fit your unique needs they have over
54 trillion trillion possible ingredient
combinations to make sure your formula
is as unique as you so basically you
take a little quiz you say I don't like
my hair is too dry or my hair's too this
or my hair is too that where I want more
of this I want more shine I have split
ends you pick what your problem areas
are stop attacking me so versus like a
traditional shampoo you get at the
grocery store it's like supposed to be
one size fits all but your hair is not
one size fits all so we love function
beauty I get the purple shampoo because
I have bleached hair and it's been
keeping my hair from going super Orange
Thank You functiona Beauty I I got I got
the peach one and the perm old peach and
it's purple colored but there's a black
one I want to get now - I think you have
the black one before happy till one of
course tell me about it oh my gosh do
not start
do not start there formulas are vegan
and cruelty free they never used so
Faith's parabens or any harmful
ingredients and they deliver it right to
your door with a cute little custom your
names printed on it or you can even put
like I'm you know miss Gina darling the
cutest girl ever I mean I don't know how
many characters you get but you can
contend with something cute you can get
one that says function of big wiener
[Music]
sure so what are you waiting for go to
function of beauty calm slash big mood
take your 4 part hair profile quiz and
save 20% on your first order
that's function and beauty calm / big
mood big mug let them know that you got
this code from our show to support the
show thank you very much that's function
of beauty comm such big mood there's a
thing at the end that's that asks you
where you heard it from and you make
sure you put cast big mood thank you or
do it so they like us so yeah where were
we romantic
oh yeah so that was the first date I
know I'm so sick of your perfect husband
Nicki I'm so sick of them but but no but
the one that really got me the most that
like he didn't he's to this day doesn't
think anything of it but it was the one
that like really just swept that one
swept me off my feet too but like this
one just really got me was I was I had
an audition and I had to print out my
resume and my printer broke it just
stopped working and I was very poor so I
couldn't just go buy another printer but
wait can't you send things like heretics
and they had like printing services at
UPS or FedEx yeah for some so so this
happened right before I was leaving to
the audit so my audition was in the
morning at like 8 a.m. and this was at
10:00 at night okay yeah and so
otherwise I would have gone to like
FedEx or whatever but he called me
because we weren't even supposed to meet
up that night or anything and he called
me and he was just asking me how my day
was and I was like I'm so [ __ ]
stressed I have this interview tomorrow
and I can't even print out my resume
and I was just flipping out and he's
like he's like I can help I can I can
get a I can get you something and I was
like everything's closed it's crazy like
there's no way I'm just [ __ ] I'm just
so [ __ ] and he shows up at my door
like [ __ ] an hour later so ready to
serve you write everything out and prove
it for you yeah it was an HP printer
yeah that was a pretty showed up with a
brand new go to Walmart oh boy I don't
know where he got it
target somewhere I don't know but it was
somewhere that was open at 10:00 at
night yeah it was in love love oh yeah
and we hadn't even waited official yet
yeah that was the one where I was like
oh my god like he like saved me knight
in shining armour notes I use your
boyfriend of Jess however you are
business idea
Steve teaches romance class all the
teacher [ __ ] how to be a man yes
yeah - all these don't be a good idea a
wonderful idea
for sure I mean Steve is another kind
but I mean I have some really cute
stories with Kate yeah Casey like makes
you breakfast and stuff is awesome Casey
because Casey does not get enough yeah
really doesn't
poor Casey hasn't in a long time he's
never made me breakfast so some negative
marks maybe it's a good thing that he
doesn't make you breakfast yeah perfect
yeah yeah well I mean Casey does make me
breakfast and he brings up my coffee
practically every morning like he's so
[ __ ] great at that and because he is
he is definitely a morning person and I
am definitely not and so he's always up
like way before me and that's the part
that's like he kind of he tells me he's
like well I wish you were kind of more
of a morning person I'm like I know it's
just really hard like I don't know it's
like working against my biology like
it's just hard but yeah he does that
every single morning but in the
beginning though like the early days the
one that like pops in my head
the earliest I can think of is when we
were in New York well actually before
going to New York I was telling him how
I wanted to take this trip and no matter
what I'm gonna be going on this trip and
I was supposed to go with some
girlfriends but the like my friends like
one by one started like dropping out of
this trip and because it was gonna be
like New Year's in New York and finally
I told him like well the last girl just
dropped out but whatever I don't care
I'm going like I have to go like I have
to do this for me and I've been wanting
to go to New York my whole life it's
gonna happen he was like well you can't
go alone and I'm like it's okay I'll be
fine I'll figure it out and he's like no
I'm gonna go with you like I'm gonna
come with you so he ended up deciding to
go with me and this was like this wasn't
me I I think it was like a couple weeks
that we had just started dating
he's already committing we were
admitting for our New York New Year's in
New York trip like it was a few we got
you tied down he's like well she can't
go anywhere cuz we're going to New
Year's yeah eight months from now yeah
no um yeah cuz I remember buying the
tickets like in the summer yeah so it
was like really early on
and so that already showed me like oh
[ __ ] that he wants to protect me like
that was a really sweet thing that he
didn't have to do and obviously like we
had just started dating where I'm like
you're really gonna take a trip like
across the country for me well I guess
he's probably thinking like well if
anything like I can still go to New York
by myself or I can just like cancel this
stuff but then he's probably thinking
like - if we stay together this long
we're gonna be super close by then it's
gonna be so cute
seriously I mean I really don't know
what his thought process was but that
was really sweet and then come December
so right before that New York trip
December comes and the home that I was
living in it was my mom's house who she
she walked away from this home meaning
like she started paying the house
payment so the bank was was repossessing
the house but there was like a huge
chunk of time that the house was just
empty and I was living in in my own
apartment so my mom was like hey stop
paying rent just go live in this house
and they'll give you a 30-day notice
before you have to leave and that's when
you can go find another apartment so
that's what I ended up doing that's the
reason why I was living in that home and
so and now
and then I got the notice during that
time I was working per diem at my job so
it wasn't like a set amount of hours I
was getting paid like hourly and my
hours weren't secured so I was getting
my hours cut more and more and it was
just like times were getting seriously
tough and I had to move out I had
nowhere to go I didn't have enough money
to put a deposit and yet Isaac I had of
course like I had a son I have a
three-year-old no four year old I had a
four year old son working a full-time
job or trying to work a full-time job
because my hours are getting cut but
yeah so it was just a really really
horrible situation to the point where I
I was planning on just living in my car
until I figure things out cuz I I had
nowhere else to go and around that exact
same time KC was getting out of his
lease with his roommates and he was
about to get an apartment on his own and
that's when he offered me like at this
point we were dating for like six months
and he's like well you can't live in
your car what the [ __ ] like come live
with me and like move in with me and I'm
like whoa like we are just dating I have
a son like that's an insane amount of
baggage to breathe it mean that's that's
a whole asked like instant family like
and so I told him like thank you so much
but I can't accept like this is too
crazy like I can't and so he was like no
please like let me help you like I can't
let you live in your car like live who
knows where so finally he ended up
convincing me to move in and so that's
when we really got insanely serious but
like he didn't have to do that you know
he could have easily been like okay
figure it out yeah but yeah like he he
opened up his home to me and Isaac and
that was really sweet sweet and that's
when like when he told me that to him
like oh [ __ ] like this this guy like
really is about protecting us and like
caring for us is like massive gestures
yeah like huge wrong huge sweeping
gestures yeah something you just
honestly I'm sitting here I've been
thinking this whole time and like I
cannot remember one romantic gesture not
one honestly can't remember anything so
I don't know if that means I don't value
it or it's
been so long there had to have been
something in all of my [ __ ] 33 32 33
years of love living but I cannot
remember one because Joe was a lot like
my dad is well my dad used to be more
romantic but like where he views like
security and like it was like he made
sure that rent was paid yeah I had a
[ __ ] at him for you know Valentine's
Day or anything and yeah that's my dad I
can't remember well I know like when we
first met it felt romantic because like
I came to LA we had taken a break and I
was in LA with my friend for some other
reasons and then we saw each other and
he kind of like just acted like really
[ __ ] happy to see me and that felt
kind of romantic but there was no actual
gesture it was just like I can't
remember any romantic gestures doing oh
well how about the opposite what are
some romantic gestures that you guys
have done for your significant others it
was nothing like it was okay so our
one-year anniversary
we both downplayed like what we got each
other but we're both the same and like
how they like want to impress the [ __ ]
out of each other so our one-year
anniversary come this time I was making
some money and um I really just like I
really like romantic gestures and so and
one-year anniversary that's like huge
you know it's one year and so I got him
tickets to the opening game of his
favorite football team the Colts playing
the Broncos in Denver so if you don't
know think about football Steve's
favorite team as the Colts that is like
a number of favorite team he always
would wear the jerseys he hardly wore
anything else back then he only would
wear Colts Jersey and then the ex
quarterback of the Colts is Peyton
Manning who was the quarterback of the
Broncos so he got to see both his
favorite quarterbacks play each other on
the opening game of football season and
so I was like I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
by plane ticket do you possibly have
done for that matter okay a day so then
he plays it a plays down his thing cuz I
was like
I just got you something little whatever
and I owe ya ticket it was like a it was
like a piece of paper and I wrapped it
in a box so it looked like clothing or
whatever and um and then you know
whatever and then he comes back he comes
to the dinner with the same size box for
my gift and he's like I just I don't
even know if you're gonna like it
blah blah and so we both open up our
gifts at the same time and there's a
vlog of this by the way I'm lucky if you
wanna check it out but we both open our
gifts up at the same time he got me Pitt
tickets to Eminem and Rihanna so I was
like there's no way I'm ever gonna see
and like the tickets are so expensive so
yeah I was like literally the only thing
stopping me from Eminem was like this
gate Shane boxers printed the same way
to see the one thing you really want to
see at the same time you guys are like
twins but that's why I was laughing
because this year was kind of a recall
to that year where honor it was our
seven-year anniversary but he was on JK
news all day and I wanted to surprise
him because he loves Mexican food and I
don't really like it that much because I
ate way too much of it when I was a
child I live in Santa Barbara and so I
kind of got burnt out of it so we hardly
ever get to go eat it even though that's
his favorite food so I decided I'll
surprise him with Mexican food he'll
come home from JK I knew what time he
usually gets home from JK so I I ordered
it to go cuz quarantine and we had plans
to go to Vegas but that got cancelled
because of quarantine so I plated it so
it was like we were eating out at a
restaurant and I lit candles and it was
like you know I romantic and this
[ __ ] is like two hours late I'm
like the food was getting hauled I was
getting so mad I was like vlogging how
like I am trying to surprise like last
minute trying to do something for you or
what no working all day he comes home
with my favorite food from my finger on
for this Italian place that didn't open
until an hour after JK got out so he was
an outside of the restaurant waiting for
it to open because he placed it to go
order and then he had to we think you
get all day no because we will try to
surprise each other
yeah the surprise with this romantic
[ __ ] sometimes it's like oh you're
trying god that's like that thing when
Ellen DeGeneres tweeted that she was
hiding from her wife scarer it took so
long because her wife was also hiding
cute yeah we just laughed he held up the
Italian food and I was like oh my god
and I showed him the Mexican meat out it
really made for each other yeah I love
that I know for me it was um there was
this one Christmas where okay so like
that whole year before I kept I I had
these like little backpack purses that I
kept using all the time and so one of
them it got messed up I forgot why but
it got ruined and I'm like [ __ ] my
backpack bruised I loved it so whatever
that's like the one from Japan that was
like yeah I think it was something like
that ran one and then so that Christmas
comes we're in Texas with this with this
family and like he saved my present for
last and then so I'm opening up this
present and it's a backpack person
brand-new backpack person I'm like oh my
god I love it so much thank you and then
he was like open it and I'm like oh [ __ ]
there's more so then I get a piece of
paper and I look at the paper and he
like there was two pieces of paper one
of them was like a letter that he wrote
and then the other one something else
was another surprise so he ends up
telling me because that was the
Christmas when we were engaged and so we
were like thinking about possibly having
our wedding in Paris so then he ends up
writing like you know so we can start
planning the wedding
get ready pack your bags for spring
break cuz we're going to Paris and then
the other the other piece of paper was a
ticket like the plane tickets to Paris
were like my goodness but before that
though because I'm us like what romantic
we have made or whatever years years
years before during our first year I
think or second year being together
I had surprised him for his birthday
tickets to Cancun and back then I was
like struggling like pretty hard to try
to make ends meet but I had saved up
every month I put money away to pay off
these Cancun tickets and so finally I
surprised him he was like what like he's
so not like a trip person but I saw em
so I'm like I thought that this would
like be like good for him cuz something
to know about Casey
especially that Casey from back then he
is a very very very closed off person
really hard to like like peel back the
layers and get to know who he is because
he's just like a clam like just shut so
it was really hard to understand like
what it was something that would mean a
lot to him so I'm like well it's kind of
a mystery in there so I'm gonna just
approach you with what would work for me
so then that's when I surprised him for
the the Cancun tickets and he was really
appreciative if he loved it during that
whole trip though cuz he's a workaholic
so he always was trying to work and I'm
like don't bring the laptops of the
beach you can't Oh God
he wanted to bring the last end of the
beat but I'm like no we're doing this
and I'm like I got us tickets to to go
to lhamo hittas which is like a smaller
island like off the coast of Cancun and
we did a whole bunch of fun stuff and
that was really fun but I just back then
I just didn't know I'm like is this
working for you yeah that's cool yeah
like if I had to buy a gift right now I
would not know what to get him
right but no he's like opened up a lot
more I mean obviously we're married so I
know him a lot better yeah but then I
did back then but yeah I wouldn't I I
guess now that cuz I'm thinking like I
don't think he was ever really romantic
but then I'm like well there's been
times where like I've said oh I want to
go you know do paddleboarding or
something and then like we'll go like do
that thing especially in Vegas and you
know what you know after clubbing and
you come home [ __ ] drunk you know
what the best thing is healthy food food
not healthy food delivery see burgers
kakaako's oh my
so and what do you how do you get that
food you oh you called or - well back
then we didn't have that but now are you
so jealous of the freakin teenagers
these days you know what this whole
quarantine thing you guys have count on
restaurants and now they're counting on
you because it's a hard it's it's
they're on some hard times right now and
while their dining rooms may be closed
they're still open for delivery with
door - door - is the app that brings you
food you're craving right now right to
your door ordering is easy open the door
- app choose what you want to eat and
your food will be left safely outside
your door with the new contact list I
love that help offset so much I'm like
can we keep this forever it's been a
problem I've been ordering food more
than once a day for the last like two
weeks outside in the front especially
cause like when I'm streaming I
conditioned myself to eat while I'm
streaming so now I just eat when I'm not
even hungry
with over 300 thousand partners in the
u.s. Berto Rico Canada and strea you can
support your local go to sore twos from
your favorite national and restaurants
like Chipotle Wendy's and my favorite
and forever favorite and my former
employer the Cheesecake Factory
many of your favorite local restaurants
are still open for delivery just open
the app select your favorite local
restaurants and your food will be left
at the door right now our listeners can
get five dull hairs off their first
order of 15 dollars or more and zero
delivery fees for their first month when
you download door - app and enter big
mood big mood that's five dollars off
your first order and zero delivery fees
for a month when you download the door -
app in the App Store and enter the code
big mood now if you're a lazy sack of
crap like me and you want food delivered
to you that's big mood for five dollars
off your first order with door - now if
you want to be more healthy you can do
what I do you can you can order some
daily harvest what I like about the
harvest is I mean also you can have the
stuff stocked up in your freezer yeah so
one thing I noticed that when quarantine
started I you know I sorry to say it was
one of those panic buyers I went to the
grocery store and I bought nothing but
like Papa
no I told paper was gone girl I was
buying nothing but carbs like
shelf-stable carbs it was so disgusting
so when daily harvest actually sent us
some samples I was so thankful because I
finally got vegetables and like real
like produce good I was so thankful to
get it and it's really good like the
vegetables but now I do I know they like
cut it up in little pieces and like
mixed different things together and the
flavors are actually just really
delicious my favorite ones the pesto one
I love the pesto let's get what it calls
the smoothies our good daily harvest
delivers clean food right to your door
all the food is built on fruits and
vegetables with no preservatives no
added sugar or any artificial
ingredients it takes just a few minutes
to prepare and I never have to question
if what I'm eating is healthy everything
in a daily harvest cup is healthy daily
harvest works directly with farms and
they freeze organic fruits and
vegetables at their peak ripeness to
lock in nutrients and taste they are the
only source of healthy food I've had yes
we need daily harvest we need you to
send more to Gina because it's the only
healthy thing she's actively dying right
now so go to daily harvest calm and
interpro mow coat big mood get $25 off
your first box that's a big discount
hmmm promo code big mood for $25 off
your first box at daily harvest calm one
last time daily harvest dot-com thank
you big mood that's a romantic gesture
thanks for that discount cooking for me
as of romantic gestures yeah dude yeah
okay so I just forgot but there was I I
went on a first date with a guy and
normally I would never meet anyone at
their house but I really like this guy
suppose like okay I'll meet him at his
house and well before that we went on a
walk on the beach and everything so I
kind of was like getting a feel for him
to make sure he wasn't super weird or
anything and then so I came back and he
cooked for me and I was like holy [ __ ]
it really was like he had su vida this
fancy cooks
he did this tri-tip or something and it
was like it was like seasoned perfectly
you know when you sous-vide something it
comes out perfectly too and then he I
watched him hand make mashed potatoes
and like you didn't help no I [ __ ]
sat there just watch i sat at the bar
and watch because I mean if it's like if
I get in his way it's probably like more
true nerve-racking for him and then he
made like broccoli with like bacon and
onions and butter and all this stuff and
we just sat there ate it I was like oh
that was really [ __ ] sweet actually
so but most of the things that people do
for me are usually like I'll mention
like before the outbreak I'll mention I
want to go here and like oh I want to go
paddleboarding or something and then so
will like he'll make it happen but I've
never had any like that's cute
typically like romantic things like yeah
that's pretty romantic in my head that
I'm global nothing really stands out
other than like they fed me or they made
sure that I got to do an activity that I
wanted to do you know why I think maybe
because you're because of your dad like
the way you're dead
thank you so maybe and yeah it just
feels like oh well my dad would cook for
me too so I don't know or maybe I'm not
registering things as romantic but I
mean but like the story you told with
the Ralph's gift card or whatever like
or a lot of stories you told that Steve
it's like those aren't typical you know
like just eating and like going out it's
like there's like he puts thought into
he went to the store bought a printer so
you could get what you needed done like
completely going out of your way things
I can't recall we need to get someone
out there to romance this [ __ ] I did
some corny [ __ ] but it's like I only
wanted if I like the guy also I oh
that's true cuz I did have a boyfriend
who would do all these things like some
of the things that he would do he was a
month or so like every month he would he
would do like a whole grand thing we see
older than high school yes and he was a
month or yes what well yeah so this guy
though so what he would do okay so like
for my 21st birthday that was kind of
sweet what he did he filled up 21
balloons and in
side of each balloon he wrote a reason
why he loved me the sweetest [ __ ] ever
but yeah so like when it's coming from
someone you're not fully into you had a
lot of other toxic traits that kind of
like I guess for someone else other than
me it would kind of like balances no I
don't know I don't know but he would do
things like very grand like he for me
Emma's compensating exactl mantak if
it's a compensation yeah right but I'm
saying I'm just highlighting like just
the gesture activities activity was like
for one month anniversary for example he
got he got thirty roses read long-stem
roses like one for every day we were
together well it's like that like that
big but the thing that made it like it
negated it all was because I don't
[ __ ] work like that like my brain
can't do the same I can't like meet his
level of it and so because I would do my
version of whatever I could it wasn't
enough for him and he'd get very upset
he whack you throw it in my face he
would be like what the [ __ ] I put all
this work and all this thought into this
[ __ ] and like that's what I mean like
you try to expect some the entire
personality is that he would treat all
his friends like that his family like
everyone was he's like I'll only give if
you're gonna give back and that's the
kind of person he was
it's gonna like for show then it's
really not out of love because when you
do something out of love you don't
expect me back that's why I kind of said
the feeling very flat like I'm like I
think it would have been amazing if it
was like if Casey would have done some
[ __ ] like that you know like it means
more but from someone like that I'm like
I feel the same way when I go on
Instagram and I see like even like Kylie
Jenner or like you know a lot of these
Instagram people who like they will show
off like this amazingly romantic [ __ ]
that their guy does for them right and I
just think like my endangered you get
instagrams like then first of all it's
fake for the gram or like they what did
they do during the rest of the year like
did they cheat on you did like what why
is this so grand and so over-the-top so
it's that rich I know for them but like
when when people kind of on our level do
[ __ ]
grant - I'm like I don't trust it for
some reason - so maybe that's why the
energy I'm putting out in the universe
oh yeah is I'm like nothing why is it so
grant but I don't think I want the grand
expensive things though I want the cute
oh speaking of month celebrators no well
maybe I was quite a fun but we did
actually celebrate her six months of our
sory he's fine it's fine you're the Ben
he was gone for it so he had left on a
road trip with his family to go to his
brother's graduation and he wanted me to
come with him but though they weren't
sure if they were gonna get me on
because it was a military base and so it
was this whole thing so he was gonna be
gone during our six month of ursery so
for the road trip I put together an
envelope for every day he was gone so he
would have something to open each day
and so one was like open this when
you're hungry and then he opened it and
it was like a gift certificate to Taco
Bell and Panda Express because we had
this joke because he couldn't tell if I
was Mexican or Asian which one you think
I am that day there and then I forget
what the other ones were but there was
like one cute thing for each like day
that he was gone cute like that yeah
doesn't do that I feel like guys don't
receive I guess I don't give a [ __ ] like
what guys think cuz I'm like what would
I want to receive or like that if I
loved somebody I felt like he loved me
the same way that I liked him so I was
like what would I want to receive to
know that they were thinking of me and
it's so personal you know and then on
the last day he was there because I was
like save this for a time you're alone
and I don't do news okay it was Danny's
no it was it was hey text this number
when you get this and it was my number
but he's like or and I said say some
code words like Marvin or something as I
say code name Marvin and so he said that
and there was a there's a football
player on the Colts named Marvin
something I can't remember his last name
but I had a female jersey of it
and so he's like hey Marvin what's up
and I was like oh what's up Steve this
is Marvin so-and-so from the cults I'm
just here with your girlfriend right now
and she wants to send you some pictures
and I had like sexy pictures of me in
that in the Jersey in that Jersey I'm
like a whole like that's catalogue those
pictures he returned that same thing of
like having a car today like a year
later when he was gone for two weeks he
had like a present a day yeah when you
talked about taking photos like that cuz
I'm like I never took photos for anyone
ever yeah but then Casey left his shirt
once at my old place mm-hmm
before we look together obviously and I
remember like I would sleep in that
shirt all the time cuz it smelled like
him and it just made me really miss him
and so I I would take really like
provocative photos and that shirt and
that's when I would say that was like
the only time ever to be alt like I said
oh yeah so whenever I'm in a
relationship I turn it into a
competition yes yeah I'm gonna win like
you can't care oh whoa whoa about what
they think yeah yeah I'm here to win
okay so at what point do you start doing
that cuz if you do that right away it's
kind of weird for them yeah okay ting
cuz you don't go too crazy at first
because chill yeah so I remember this
guy the first time he won because I told
him he won yeah out Romancing you out
really missed me I hadn't mentioned
something that I've wanted ever since I
was a kid I literally mention it in
passing I can't say what it is cuz I'll
date it okay and then people know but I
mentioned it in passing like but
probably mumbled it and then for
Christmas I got it I opened it I saw the
box and I was just like and then just
like tears oh my god wonder since I was
kid and it was like so the next time was
so I do not like arts and crafts hated
what I am terrible at it
oh he you know seemed very crafty no I'm
not you know I can't lady glue my
fingers to my face somehow but he loves
like really personal arts and crafts
things so I stayed up so late it was
like 15 hours long working on the single
I remember this it probably could have
taken a normal person three hours but
because you're not crafty it lasted
fifteen exactly so I started the night
before supposed to give it to him and I
was like oh my god like this is way too
much work and then I stayed up until
like 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning was
like 15 hours and I made this it's
called an exploding box you lift off the
lid in the box just like opens with like
photos and notes whatever like I I
started like I'm head I cried a few
times I'm mental breakdowns yeah
but sounds hard to make it was awesome
to die but if a man leaves you after you
spend 15 hours doing a [ __ ] exploding
box he deserves to be murdered and then
inside that was a really wonk of
golden-ticket because he always said
dating you was like getting the golden
ticket that's right and he would sing
the song I got the golden tour the
factory like the time I got it
custom-made so I looked at what it said
originally and I changed it to whoever
holds his ticket has endless blah blah
blah from Gina whatever so I got him
that and then but for his birthday it
was a really big birthday and I was like
we are gonna go all out cuz I won with
the box yeah but I wanted to
back-to-back win right
so it was reigning champion mmm great
back to back reading Jean yeah so it was
his birthday he had nothing planned I'm
like you can't have nothing planned it's
a big birthday this is like a milestone
birthday so I texted him the night
before I was like hey pack your stuff
pack a suit and then meet me at my house
tomorrow and he said me and there's
nowhere to go I'm like you talk too much
and so you shut up shut your mouth and
then so you know he met up with me said
where we go and I'm like shut up you
talk too much like wouldn't tell him
anything
and then drove him I had booked out a
hotel in Beverly Hills and I was like
okay wait in the lobby
while I go upstairs to
prep everything I put up balloons that
said happy birthday I got a cake with
his favorite comic-book character in it
on I facetimed I had to Instagram
FaceTime one person one best friend I
had to Facebook FaceTime another best
friend and I propped them up because
they couldn't be there for his birthday
and then I got him he loves suits so I
got him like Tom Ford ties whatever that
he's been wanting on eBay like he was
like scrolling through it he's like oh
I'm bidding for this on eBay and I'm
like and then instead of bidding I just
bought all of it and then I got him a
blanket that he wanted from his
childhood and then so um I was like okay
you can come up now and then like the
concierge gave him his key let him in
and then he opened the door is me and
his I'm holding a camera and a cake and
singing happy birthday to him and then
um so what he does when he doesn't know
what to do is that he panic cleans oh my
God thank you so much yeah I didn't I
told him to pack a suit because I know
that he loves taking photos to
commemorate things so I was like pack
your favorite suit yeah that's awesome
however there was one time I did
something sweet for a guy and it kind of
backfired what happened this is when I
was like 19 my boyfriend at the time
just moved into a new place by himself
his first time by himself I was like
okay for Christmas I'm gonna surprise
him with the little Christmas tree I was
broke as [ __ ]
I'm surprised him with the Christmas
tree I'm gonna decorate it's gonna be
his first lien my first Christmas tree
at my new place and like I spent the
whole day he was out at work I spent the
whole day decorating it put on the
lights and I was waiting for him to put
the star on and then so he comes home
and I was like hi babe he goes oh hey
and then he walks to his room I was like
I was like babe come here he goes what
it was like I got you a tree cuz oh cool
thanks and I'll say what the hell [ __ ]
do you want to put the star on it with
me he's like oh yeah sure and then just
and then it turns out he's cheating on
me oh Jesus yeah so that ain't Kerry
yeah it was like the like when someone
does a romantic thing and you don't
yeah that's uh yeah I hope all those
Christmases sucked up yeah
jinxed all of them lovely romantic
gestures what would be your ideal
romantic gesture Jess gesture gesture
gesture yeah for all of you watching out
there the morning they know how to woo
you know I feel like it would have to be
personal and I have to be related to the
relationship so it's hard to say yeah
you know like I wouldn't I don't want
some cookie cutter thing I just wanted
to like make sense right and to just
feel like thought of and but then also
like I know what I'm reflecting on all
the [ __ ] you guys are doing I'm like
well I'm not really creating that
environment myself mm-hmm so you put it
in the yeah so it just needs to be like
be romance a little romantic gestures to
dogs deserve it I'll just say I just I
yesterday started watching Korean
romance dramas and now my expectation
for men is impossible why they do it was
a billionaire who doesn't know how to
date but he falls in love with his
secretary and he doesn't know how to
date properly so he shuts down a whole
entire amusement park to let her ride
the merry-go-round seven times so now if
you don't do that I don't want it stupid
alright well if anybody wants to mood
Jess leave a comment
she is romantic bring the romance and
you'll get the room exact yeah you'll
have to teach me how to put things in
the universe so that they come back to
me or start with your pets look at that
how this [ __ ] treats her cat so many
presents she even bought my cat presents
I'm like yeah even my cat step on my kid
he's taken I'm stealing everyone we love
you guys a romantic gesture for us that
would be much appreciated as if you
would go to iTunes and write us five
stars that is so hard
oh and leave a comment on romantic
gestures you've done or have been done
see I need some ideas yeah some ideas
that would use to the people like some
not basic [ __ ] we don't need the basic
[ __ ] yeah that's why I've been sitting
here this whole time thinking I'm like
oh my shits really basic Cancun is not
basic coos not baby that's yeah in Paris
yeah no no I'm saying like that I've
done oh it's like I'm not saying Casey's
gestures were basic I'm just saying like
I don't know like it's rip my brain just
doesn't it's hard not get it like I get
it white guys struggle yeah I get it I
get it yeah peace out yellow thank you
guys we'll see you guys next week I am I
love you